funderwear people Durex is bringing us
funderwear
it allows touch to be transferred over
the internet but don't take my word for
it let's let's watch this clip
it feels like a cutscene
okay that gives a whole new meaning to
iPod touch alright I mean what this has
been coming for a long time right should
we be surprised by oh no it was real
they are gooey we are going to be
wearing electronic underwear an
electronic bras and it is gonna be
hooked up and you're gonna be skyping
with your husband or your lover or
whoever or a random stranger and they're
gonna be touching things and vibrating
how do you feel about I'm wearing them
right now actually I'm not wearing them
but I do have my cell phone in my pants
which is the old-school way of doing
this yeah I mean this is this the future
this is a future of sex right this is it
we saw this coming
I think that that girl when she was like
it feels like you're touching me I was
like she just looks annoyed like
someone's like scraping her like is
there a finger inside that underwear or
a hand because first of all this is the
first generation I don't want them to
have clothes on isn't that kind of the
point it's not very sexy when you're
like you're wearing a sports bra and
thick panties yeah
not that I'd be sexting with her or
whatever but the whole thing is weird to
me you're rubbing the phone instead of
how do you touch yourself at the same
time it's just no you don't touch
yourself they're they're controlling you
that could be a [ __ ] you want to assist
them like if it's not enough right what
if you dial the wrong phone number yeah
there's a lot of problems everything
about that just looked too confusing an
ill thought out to me right and also
what about people wearing this just
during the day mister is sitting at work
well what are you doing are you texting
right now I guess yeah but why let's cut
out the middle bronze to me it right it
just looked like a lot just put on a
hazmat suit and Rory I mean is it for
germophobes I guess it's for Jeremy it's
for long distance relationship think
about money and you buy a plane ticket
and go and visit
that's the thing they want to sell this
as like you know it's bringing people
closer but again this is like our social
media which we talk about all the time
on this show like are these things
actually bringing us closer or maybe if
you're in a long-distance relationship
you need to wait it out until you until
you get actually in person it's reason
enough to be like I'll come next week
instead like there's no instead I it
just looks creepy to me yeah you want
this I can tell me I'm not even saying
it couldn't go to something else I don't
need you to research how to make the bra
tangle
yeah put that money towards something
good do the research on how to teach you
how to touch me better right right so
that's that's the part I guess that
instead of dealing with like the real
intimacy issues that everybody has yeah
you know straight gay whatever that were
like jump we're just pushing everything
into the digital space and it's like so
instead of having to look someone in the
eye and have sex with them or whatever
you're doing with them well we'll Skype
this we're gonna Skype and we're you
remove the human part the human part is
the scent and you're losing that if
you're skyping the the relationship
until they have smell-o-vision mask on
which is gonna be even more attractive
yeah I think they had that right one day
we're just gonna be in a box and the
other person is gonna be in a box and
it's gonna be do you think gay people
are gonna get on this first because gays
seem to always be the early adopter no
because I already have their apps that
they don't need to touch each other with
they find an app they find someone 26
feet away to come over and touch them
and then go home it's done yeah and you
don't have to keep your underwear on I
wouldn't touch it with a 10-foot Pole
right I wonder how much more brazen
people will be sexually though with
things like this you know I mean you
might be willing to do things like what
though I think the range of motion just
seemed very much like this right so I
don't know how risky you can go like
what if you want to like if you have an
iPad you have a bigger range of motion
well maybe that's overweight people I
don't I don't know but I don't I just
don't want someone touching me like this
yeah I want someone with free I want a
sensor on every piece of that which
means you need a whole
suit then yeah it's just a disaster
waiting up you gonna end up you jump in
the pool with your underwear on you get
electrocuted and your battery dies and
the person and the other ends doesn't
someone there's call waiting someone
send you a text and everything fries
there's a three-way three-way how do you
do a three-way I don't even like 3-way
calling yeah yeah alright well in just a
matter of weeks I'll be wearing these
underwear and you guys will be able to
you know rub your dial and decent stuff
to me bonobos comm is the official
outfitter of the Rueben report use code
TRR to zero for 20% off your first
purchase